So today we are jumping into a new series
to go over something a little more dark and
mysterious than usual.
Of course if the thumbnail and title weren't
enough this is no other than the most recent
complete arc from the back breaking genius
himself TOGASHI and his amazing series of
Hunter Hunter.
With the news that we have more hunter hunter
chapters dropping for literally the first
time in freaking years, I think its time we
dive in to the most recent complete arc of
the series WHICH takes place DIRECTLY after
the anime ends.
SO YES everything in this video follows straight
after the final episode with Gon and his daddio
atop that massive ass tree and it pretty much
just elaborates on everything that is going
down inside of this so called dark continent.
If you want me to cover even more of the recent
Hunter Hunter stuff, push this video to like
5k likes and leave a comment down below as
it truly helps out with just pushing my content
to new people!
Anyways enough of that lets get into the start
of the Hunter Hunter Dark Continent Expedition
Arc!
So as things kick off we find the lil green
man himself Beans who’s actually not green
in the manga but oh well, he barges into the
Zodiacs' conference room shouting about a
big emergency as Cheadle at the same time
was also about to make a large announcement.
The Zodiacs initially think that she will
quit as the chairman, but Cheadle assures
them before letting Bean talk.
He shows a video in which the Kakin Empire's
King a large man named Nasubi Hui Guo Rou,
goes on a rant about "bearing all of humanities'
future dreams on their back.“ From this
he ends up declaring that they the Kakin Empire
will advance into the Dark Continent.
Hearing this the Zodiacs are all taken aback,
aside from Kanzai who’s completely clueless
about the Dark Continent.
Gel explains that the Dark Continent is a
place that can't be found on the world map,
but is where other human-like beings and other
magical beasts thrive.
Mizaistom also adds in that every other time
humans have tried to go there disasters have
fallen apon them back at home.
Due to this happening a few times, 200 years
ago the five leading nations of the world,
called the V5, made a treaty not to go there.
Cheadle explains that 30 years ago, Kakin
technically became a new nation by taking
advantage of an incident and jacking the countries
monarchy turning it into a parliamentary democracy,
at which time they likely did not renew their
treaties or frankly just threw them away.
As the Zodiacs continue to discuss, Beans
interrupts pointing at the screen and stating
that in fact the really troubling part actually
comes next.
Looking back at the video, it shows Nasubi
as he introduces the person that will lead
the expedition to the Dark Continent.
He proudly announces the legendary pro hunter
Isaac Netero, the previous chairman of the
Hunter Association, and states that they have
hired his son, Beyond Netero to lead the expedition.
The Zodiacs are surprised once again as they
all react to the news of Netero having a son.
Dude literally never even bought his son up
once throughout the previous 150 damn episodes
of the manga.
Gel suggests that they verify if it's true
or not, but as Beyond starts to give a speech,
multiple Zodiacs immediately recognize his
resemblance to the late chairman.
Beyond promises that he will take care of
everything, and that everyone will have an
equal opportunity in this new world.
He screams and encourages everyone to come
to Kakin so they can embark on their journey
to the new world, leaving everyone watching
the video inside the room shaken.
Beans discloses that there were in fact 2
DVDs t Chairman Netero left behind.
As Beans slides the second DVD onto the table
he explains that Netero told him to show all
members of the Zodiacs the other DVD if anyone
came forth claiming to be his son.
However, Ging and Pariston are absent so he’s
unable to proceed further, because of this
Cheadle interrupts the arguing zodiacs to
begins her own announcement.
Yet we aren't exactly privy to this information,
as instead we skip away from the zodiacs to
learn that currently the people of the world
are blown away with Beyond Netero’s announcement
and cant stop watching it on their version
of YouTube.
Beyond who’s literally just big chilling
having a few drinks, overhears that the king
has been notified by V5 to revoke the previous
announcement and instead sign the treaty.
After literally getting the Togashi treatment
and having a book of information shoved in
his face by his curly haired friend.
An annoyed Beyond decides to ignore the permissions
of the V5 about exploring the Dark Continent,
as he wants to explore the unknown world without
supervision.
Standing there and just looking mad jacked,
He says to his 10 important followers, one
of which just happens to be that damn snake
Pariston, that he is willing to see a land
that nobody has ever seen, meeting people
no ones met, obtaining things no ones ever
touched and all by his own volition without
being restrained by no one!
So skipping away from Beyond we learn that
Cheadle’s news was that they don't actually
need to wait for Ging and Pariston to see
the DVD, as they resigned as members of the
Zodiacs.
Therefore there are now only 10 Zodiacs, allowing
them to fulfil the conditions and also on
top of that that, something that's actually
more important than the previous two, the
V5 have already given them a special assignment:
to hunt Beyond Netero.
The IPA Director and the newly assigned Deputy
Secretary, Steiner, who are both associated
with the V5, walk through a heavily secured
hallway and discuss their role of the organization
in accordance with the upcoming journey to
the Dark Continent.
As they enter an elevator, the Director mentions
that the "Gatekeeper of the New World" hates
ill-mannered visitors and should the negotiations
with the Kakin Empire break down it will be
very difficult to stop them.
Steiner asks what would happen, to which the
older executive talks about "Pandora's Box"
being opened, which Steiner questions as a
figure of speech.
However, the Director explains that he once
thought that, back when he was young and before
he came here.
He then opens a door to the International
Permit Agency basement that's filled with
various atrocities and corpses resulting from
the last entry into the Dark Continent.
The bewildered deputy stutters wondering what
the hell this could be, to which its revealed
that all these atrocities used to be human.
The Director hands over a book called Journey
to the New World to Steiner, explaining that
it was once considered fiction but is now
a legendary text that contains travels to
the dark continent from hundreds of years
ago.
The Director further explains that all of
the wrung corpses in the basement were discovered
on this side or more specifically in the known
world, and none of them had ever travelled
to the Dark Continent.
He instructs Steiner to memorize every detail
of the book and identify the risks of traveling
to the "New World"…
As they walk along through the basement, one
creature slams against the glass, which takes
Steiner in surprise.
The Director explains that this one creature
is the lone survivor in their facility, but
it is no longer human.
The creature does not need sustenance like
humans do, and has already lived for 50 years
being completely self sustaining.
Every attempt humanity has made at exploring
the Dark Continent has resulted in them fleeing
home and bringing a calamity of mass destruction
with them.
The Director continues that the creature was
once a Hunter who was exposed to a virus that
renders him immune to death.
Meanwhile, the Zodiacs watch the second DVD
where former chairman the OG BIG Netero explains
that his randomly mysterious son Beyond once
travelled to the Dark Continent and brought
back new threats that resulted in considerable
casualties, so he forbade further attempts
by Beyond and the Hunter Association until
after his own death.
Netero explains that he’s only set foot
there twice and when he was young, but he
personally realized the strength required
to remain there wasn't what he sought.
The new world was a harsh battle against mother
nature itself where no victor exists.
Netero declares that he wants the Hunter Association
to explore the Dark Continent before his son,
telling them to overcome the risks of the
new world and return with hope as the difficulty
is undisputedly A!!
Though quickly before ending he emphasizes
that it is a request rather than an order
and its completely upto them to choose.
Cheadle accepts the mission saying that since
its an order they literally have no other
choice, but states that no other Hunters in
the organization should join them.
Saiyu and Kanzai assert their opposition to
Beyond's hunt, stating that it makes the race
to the New World unfair as Beyond has been
preparing for this moment for decades.
One of the Zodiacs ask if any of them have
actually thought about going to the mentioning
that Ging is the only one they can think of
who has the ambition to go to the Dark Continent.
Gel says that if Ging does help, the race
will be fair for arguments sake, otherwise,
Kakin and beyond will have a big head start.
As all of the Zodiacs argue over their next
course of action, Beans suddenly receives
a call from someone mysterious.
With all of the Zodiacs having followed beans,
its revealed that Beyond Netero had indeed
just called him and now appears before the
Zodiacs.
Standing there he firstly gives the what's
up to big beans as obviously he’s beeeeen
around for years oml fml anyways he instructs
them to call the V5, telling them that they
have "captured" Beyond Netero leaving all
of the Zodiacs shocked with the absolutely
unpredictable turn of events.
Elsewhere, Steiner begins his forte into the
prolific book that he is supposed to memorize.
There its shown that the five threats humanity
has previously brought back from the new world
are, The codependence of Desire which is a
gaseous life-form ai, A Sphere that protects
mysterious ruins called the botanical weapon
Brion, A monster that infects its prey with
a homicidal desire known as the snake hell
bell.
This ones my fave, the trade off between life
and pleasure known as a beast that keeps people
as its pets and finally, endless despair disguised
as hope Zobae, the immortality disease.
After reading all this, Steiner only reflects
thinking that this indeed is no place humanity
should venture.
So back with the Zodiacs its shown that Beyond
is now being kept within a cell while Cheadle
interviews him, and the rest of the Zodiacs
stand by and watch.
Sitting there in a seemingly helpless situation
Beyond makes a prediction that the Zodiacs
will end up releasing and joining him in his
expedition to the Dark Continent.
Cheadle quickly dismisses the idea though,
calling it an unrealistic delusion, but still
Beyond tells her to hear him out before v5
make their own report.
Having placed a recorder on the table, Cheadle
proposes that their conversation shall be
recorded, which beyond accepts, however as
she stares at him, she knows Beyond is technically
on the offensive, while she and the Zodiacs
have to decode and figure him out.
Elsewhere, the V5 and Deputy Secretary, Steiner,
discuss the previous Dark Continent expeditions.
Its shown, that their world is actually located
in the centre of the massive lake Mobius of
which itself if also located within the dark
continent.
In their records, there are 149 attempts to
challenge the voyage, but out of that only
28 people survived from the five trips that
managed to return.
Out of them Beyond is the only one who is
still alive today.
Those said 5 voyages that returned were also
unofficial and took place after the v5 formed
the inviolability treaty, so mankind has never
official succeeded in making a round trip
to the New World.
Out of the 28 survivors, only three were able
to return to their ordinary lives which makes
this a survival rate of 0.04 percent.
One old ass hag of an employee asks about
"guides", and another member answers that
they are a race of people called "gate-keepers"
who summon a being to help transport people
to the Dark Continent.
As a few people talk amongst themselves, a
larger man interrupts pointing out that any
talk of risk only adds as fuel to the fire
for countries and businesses that pour money
into this stuff in hope they'll get a return.
Another employee implies that they need to
know the official way to be able to stop Kakin
from advancing towards the new world.
Steiner explains that article 4 of the UN
chartered basic relations treaty states that
international threats clauses 7 thru 9 prohibit
active involvement with contagious diseases,
biological hazards and unknown menaces, but
if its determined that a nation is at risk
then the use of force including military intervention
is permitted!
ANND as we know from the freaking chimera
arc, when the army is involved they are dropping
some next level biological weaponry, pppooobably
implanted inside of some poor dude!
Annnyways Steiner says that considering this,
to end the situation in a peaceful matter
its necessary to invite Kakin to the V5, then
through that they will reorganize as the V6
and unofficially support Kakins journey to
the New world, making them also look good
in turn.
Steiner continues explaining that there are
tones of uninhabited islands in the neutral
zone inside of the far ocean boundary, so
they can just pretend that are apart of the
new continent and have the civilians spend
their lives there, while they can leave the
actual voyage to Kakin, BUT only on the condition
that members are carefully selected.
which makes sense as you don't want some weak
nobody's just rolling into the dark continent
possibly putting others in harms way, like
everybody needs to be able to hold there own.
Back over with out hunters, As Cheadle and
Beyond continue on their interview, Kanzai
is just utterly perplexed about the conversation
asks someone to translate it for him.
Saccho simply answers that Beyond got a ticket
to the dark continent in exchange for making
Kakins king a historical hero, but because
the V5 doesnt like to lose they are making
the zodiacs babysit beyond.
Kanzai asks if its good for them and Gel explains
that technically its good and bad as if they
succed its possible theyll be allowed to hunt
on the continent.
Back inside the cell, Beyond insists that
cheadle contact the V5, he thinks that theyll
say “tell Beyond they’d accept a supervised
voyage and that the chaperone will be the
hunter association.
After a moment Cheadle accepts under the condition
that he’s telling the truth, but first they
have to confirm some stuff.
She asks Mizaistom to contact the V5.
Instantly outside of the room its confirmed
that the Zodiacs will indeed go to the Dark
Continent with Beyond, even against their
will.
When Kanzai gets confused AGAIN, Gel explains
that Beyond will be transported to the Dark
Continent as a prisoner, but somehow he’ll
probably escape, leaving them with the task
of fighting off threats, maintaining Beyond
and somehow stopping his comrades from interfering.
Once everyone begins to leave, Saccho offers
to watch over Beyond to which cheadle accepts.
She then turns to the imprisoned man and tells
him that he should be prepared as it will
be a LONG imprisonment and hearing this, Beyond
laughs as he says HELL WAIT AS LONG AS IT
TAKES!
Earlier as everyone left the meeting room,
Steiner thinks outloud about how their official
stance is that the book he read recently is
a writer's fantasy, but in actuality the book
is the most important peice of criteria on
the planet.
Cracking up and slapping him on the back the
IPA Director replies that hell be a great
manager just like him, ofcourse an honest
world would be best, yet peace is a much more
important manner.
In some other place, the Black Whale transport
ship is presented to the people.
It is said to carry about 200,000 people,
and in the next 5 years, King Nasubi has declared
that he will send 500 ships to the Dark Continent,
which totals to around about 100 million people.
(Man is actually tryna exterminate the lives
of 100 million innocent civilians.
Aint no way a normal man surviving in this
domain of death.
Anyways, The TV reporters continue to explain
that the maiden voyage will carry Beyond,
the King, and 14 princes, any civilians will
be picked by lottery and those odds are only
1 in 1300.
In a recording studio, more reporters discuss
the bestiary known to mankind (which is that
book all the hunters have that rank certain
threats).
A female reporter asks someone to explain
to them in terms they would understand, how
dangerous is the C class ranking.
The man states that its things, like bears,
sharks, poisonous snakes etc, stuff you might
come across if your unlucky that might turn
fatal in the worst case senario.
Another anchor states that opinions online
declare that the Dark Continent surely must
harbor Rank B or A creatures.
Laughing in response, the random man says
well ofcourse no body can count them out completely,
but these people also assume that mankind
has never even ventured there in the past
because dangerous creatures exist.
OML the ammount of information Togashi is
shoving down my throat rn, Anyways Continuing
Many ancient ruins describe the calamities
caused by going to the continent.
Science has concluded that these mass casualties
were from infections and viruses, now with
modern medicine they will easily be able to
prevent such problems from occuring.
On top of that the stuff they do find is much
more likely to be hiding miraculous compounds
that can help mankind advance further than
it ever has before.
As the broadcast comes to an end, that dude
declares that this will be the greatest goldrush
in all of human history.
Having rolled up as the broadcast was finishing
on the TV Ging Freecss the big man himself
arrives in the lair of Beyond's Dark Continent
Expedition Team, and confronts Pariston Hill.
Ging explains that if the government doesn't
answer to Beyond's taunt and send them to
the Dark Continent, Pariston in response would
force there hand and send in 5,000 Chimera.
He continues telling him that he will no longer
allow Pariston to do as he pleases and tells
him that he’s now going to play with him
personally until he begs him to stop.
Pariston looks at Ging with his deep dark
eyes he responds confidently asking if he’s
finally going to pay him some attention.
Ging who’s visibly disgusted with Pariston
just answers that he might just be doing it
for his own fun…
Cheadle contacts one of the OG OG’s Leorio
over the phone, and invites him to become
a member of the Zodiacs.
She explains that the association thinks that
his skills are best suited to fill the position
and they absolutely need his help the upcoming
mission.
When Leorio implies that he will turn down
the offer, Cheadle continues to say that there
is a medical study waiting for him and that
she will be the head medical professor herself.
Hearing this, Leorio who in most cases wouldve
rejected the offer ends up accepting as he
knows that theres no chance this will ever
happen again in his life.
He thanks her for granting him this opportunity,
however he has just one request, he asks Cheadle
if there is still another position available
in the Zodiacs because if there is he has
someone he’s like to recommended for the
post.
AND WE KNOW WHO THAT EYE COVERTING CHAIN WEILDING
KING IS!!
In the lair of Beyond’s Dark Continent Expedition
Team, which btw has literally the scary girl
maze game picture now featured on the TV,
Not sure why Togashi decided to chuck this
in here, BUT HOLY it plays to the feeling
of the meeting having this scary ass pic of
a child featured on the television.
There Pariston states that the Hunter Exam
will begin soon, and that he knows Ging is
aware of the 5000 Chimera Ants he has hidden
away as a back up to force V5 into into the
expedition.
He thinks Cheadle will separate the Hunter
Exam from the organization, which Pariston
disapproves of.
When Ging asks him why he would want to destroy
the Hunter Association despite feeling attached
to it, Pariston asks him to prove it, starting
from his motives.
Ging starts to explain that Pariston is seeking
something new that could entertain him as
the association has started to tire him, because
of this Ging assumes that Pariston thought
it was time to move on and find new targets.
The fastest way is by scattering the Chimera
Ants across the world, while also opening
the previously illegal routes to the Dark
Continent.
He continues to say that Pariston's underlings
might easily pass the Exam, and become organizational
members.
However, he cannot see the link between why
pariston would brandish the treat of the Chimera
Ants against the association.
He concludes by proclaiming that Pariston
and he are kindred spirits and there ideas
are always a tiny bit off the beaten track.
Pariston's smile weakens as he concedes that
Ging is spot-on.
He reflects that normally people find happiness
in loving and being loved, but he feels happy
most when he is hated and he continually feels
this irrepressible need to destroy the things
he loves.
Malevontly he wonders aloud if it is all that
weird, with Ging replying that Pariston is
completely off the mark and asserting they
are different in that respect.
Curly quietly tries to ask a question, but
is completely shunned by Ging, much to his
dismay.
Usamen this Hajimo looking wannabe stands
up and threatens the former Boar zodiac, but
before he can do anything, he is lifted up
by Ging and imagines his own face being caved
in by the latter's plethora punches.
Coming back to reality, the dude realised
he probably just witnessed his own death as
Ging then orders him to get lost if he understands,
then quickly looking around the room he finds
a "robotic girl" in the corner and asks if
she is the highest-ranked person.
Pariston interrupts his intruding though and
calls himself the obvious number two within
the team.
Ging observes with surprise that people are
not ranked by strength, releasing Usamen.
Pariston objects he is being underestimated
but Ging coldly states he would end up killing
him if they were to fight, however he would
continue to display his disgusting smile and
laugh unless his very spirit was defeated.
He then declares himself number two and challenges
anyone that opposes him.
Mizaistom the big COW of the Zodiacs heads
out in search of Kurapika.
(as that was obviously the person Leorio recommended
for the position.)
Once arriving at Kuripikas place, Linssen
informs him that he’s currently out but
can leave a message for him if he’d like.
Mizaistom insists to wait mans literally like
can I have a coffee and DW ill manage with
the milk which is insane hahaha anyways, but
three men block his pathway.
Calmly though the COW KING pulls out and shows
them a warning card, which indicates that
acts of violence are not allowed.
When the men move to attack him, Mizaistom
uses the card to restrain the men's movements,
most likely apart of his Nen ability called
Cross Game.
Sitting down in the corner of the room, he
tells the men they’ll all be able to move
in a moment, but warns them that if they try
and resist more itl continue to imobilize
them.
Finally, the bartender interupts, telling
him that Kurapika is in the basement, he warns
the cow to not anger him as Kurapika is really
upset about something that concerns their
group.
Before he can finish explaining though, Kurapika
himself appears asking what all the noise
is and how the random man wearing a cow uniform
in his house is.
Mizaistom introduces himself from the Hunter
Association and asks Kurapika about the news
regarding the Dark Continent expedition.
He invites him to join the Zodiacs under the
request of Leorio, but Kurapika quickly declines,
telling him that he is busy.
Mizaistom suddenly brings up the prolific
Scarlet Eyes, which incites anger in Kurapika,
setting his own scarlet eyes alight with the
fire of all of his fallen clan members.
He makes his chains appear and threatens Mizaistom,
telling him to carefully choose his words
from now on.
Mizaistom reports that on the web there is
an illegal website in which criminals will
sell rare items through.
6 Months ago, someone posted a video in which
a number of scarlet eyes are visible.
Having seen this video himself, Kurapika already
knows about the content within it.
However the COW KING then reveals that they
managed to find the owner of those eyes, something
that Kurapika and his crew were completely
unable to do.
He tells him that, they would all like him
to join the Zodiacs and take part in the expedition
to the new world.
An expedition that will last approximately
2 months, he asks him to carefully study the
ins and out of the proposal before coming
to a decision.
Kurapika considers the offer thourougly thinking
about how its a priority of his to recover
the stolen eyes, because of this he joins
on the spot so he can find out the true identity
of the person who owns these eyes.
After a moment, Mizaistom pulls out a picture
and gives it to Kurapika, its explained that
this man, the fourth Prince of the Kakin Empire,
Tserriednich Hui Guo Rou is the confirmed
owner of the stolen scarlet eyes.
Kurapika recalls how he acquired the previous
sets of Scarlet Eyes that are now in his possession
going over all of the people he’s had to
take down in his head, finally ending on the
man who is his current target, the son of
a king.
Remembering Pairo, Kurapika realizes that
his joirney is finally beginning, he wonders
where he may go, a place where he’s greated
or one in which can call home…
However he sadly remembers that he no longers
has anything like that at all in his life…
Back in the lair of Beyond's Dark Continent
Expedition Team, the members are still doubtful
of having Ging as the second in command behind
Beyond.
Two members even decide to fight against him,
but Ging quickly offers them money instead.
He promises to double Beyond's pay to the
members and will pay them in advance.
Apart from that he says that he has nothing
else to offer them and he also has no requests
to make of them.
He asks if they have anyquestions and not
to hesitate as he’ll answer with pleasure.
Another member who seemed skeptical over whether
or not he’ll get paid asks if he’s sure
he doesnt have any other requests to make
of the group, to which ging again tells them
NO and to trust them..
Ging says that if they allow him to be the
No.2 theyll all be paid accordingly and the
case will be closed.
That skeptical member gives Ging his account
number, and only a few moments later after
visibly being suprised at the money in his
account, leaves the lair with the other mombers
noting that he probably wont come back.
Ging asks Pariston if he has objections, in
which Pariston actually says he’s happy
with the turn of events.
Back over in the Hunter Association building,
Leorio manages to get in contact with Kurapika,
who is currently traveling by car with the
cow king mizai.
Kurapika asks about Gon, and Leorio abrushes
it off saying he’s fine but he needs his
support in the association.
After some random antics between the two boys
Kurapika ends the call and thanks Mizaistom
for the connection to the Prince, though he
knows his abilities will not help much for
them during the expedition.
Mizaistom warns Kurapika that the prince has
a darker side, he knows he’ll probably act
recklessly either way when confronted with
him, but still he hells him to try and use
the safest method and avoid detection.
Kurapika hearing this though reassures him
that he has dealt with monsters in human shells.
(Which is so true, like Kurapika is just a
pure Genius when it comes to taking down an
enemy.
Man was so confident with the phantom troupe
he brought a damn spade to his fight with
uvogin..
Anyways Elsewhere FOR THE FIRST TIME WE SEEE
the lil man himself Gon as he tries to activate
his Nen, but is surprised when he finds out
he cannot access it any longer.
Obviously if youve seen the anime which you
should have, youll know why.
Honestly im assuming that Gon probably has
to start from square one all over again and
build back up his Nen.
idk let me know what you think down below!
Ahh sadly though we skip away from the previous
main character of the series, over to the
evolved verson of Gon, Ging as he details
the previous Five Threats of the Dark Continent
to a few members from Beyond's Expedition
Team.
He explains that these threats are stronger
than the Chimera Ants and people have no countermeasure
against them.
He continues that the victims of Ai and Pap
have been found, and a sixth threat might
return.
One of Beyonds allies asks why in the world
would they want to even travel there, is there
even anything they could possibly gain!
OKAY so Ging kinda blows there minds, he goes
way more indepth on the distances around the
continent, where to find certain materials
around this new world that can physically
change the world they live in and the beasts
protecting these precious locations, ores
or materials.
Continuing He explains that the hunter association
had also orgainized a an expedition with Netero
and a few mates, but there is no given official
information on this trip.
According to Netero himself though, that land
is just utterly monstrous and all of these
adventures were supposed to serve as a warning!
In order to prevent Beyond or his son from
travelling to the Dark Continent, Isaac and
the V5 placed a ban over the place and any
ship that would be sent towards the new world
would be hit with the seal of the fobidden.
Standing there Ging asks the people infront
of him if they are still ready to take up
the challange, but interupting them the member
from before who received money and gapped
it returned stating that he’s ready!
Infront of a shocked group the younger bloke
tells them that all his money was spent to
save his younger sister in the hospital and
because of that he’s infinitely grateful
to him.
He agrees that Ging is now undoubtedly second
place within the team.
Then the moment that I love most happens,
Ging having found out that dudes story, tells
him that he cant afford to let him die, but
he will also make sure that he can keep the
ammount Beyond offered him.
GING is an actual chad, im assuming he means
he’ll let the young man stay in saftey on
the homeland while still getting him the fat
pay day!
Dudes making up for all the random shit he
put Gon through throughout the main story!
Stepping up the trippy dude or chick im not
to sure named Curly, asks Ging about the reference
of all the information about the Dark Continent.
Ging explains that every generation has there
nutters, but some 300 years ago someone explored
the shoes of Moebius on their own and this
person wrote the memoirs of his explaination
called, The Memories of A New World Traveler
East and West.
YET ging sadly explains that until today only
one copy has been found, with not the slightest
trace of the west book anywhere!
After Mascher and another team member give
two possible reasons as to why it might not
have been found, Ging gives a third, one so
damn insane I had to double check id written
the correct text: He says that the book is
still being written as they speak and as everyone
reacts surpised over this bizzare statment,
he contines revealing that the author is no
one other that Don Freecss.
THE ANCIENT ANCESTOR OF GON AND GING FREECSS!
Gon talks to Ging on the phone and informs
his father that he is not able to bring any
aura out.
Ging replies to this by saying that while
(Gon's) aura most probably is coming out as
it was when they were together atop the tree,
he just can't see it himself.
Pretty much Meaning that Gon had now returned
to 'normal' or just a normal human state.
He then states to him that he should be thankful
as that is all that happened to him, he could
have easily lost a lot more.
He then advises Gon to take this opportunity
to figure out what he can do as he is now.
Gon heeds his father's advice and returns
to Whale Island, reunites with Mito, and helps
her with the housework just like he used to
wayyy back at the begining of the series,
Man I love the nostalgia hit this lil island
gives me, I havent seen the hxh anime in years
but it was one of the first series I ever
completed, just knowing now that our man makes
it home to fully wrap up his story is perfect.
Anyways, during dinner, Mito questions Gon,
asking him if he was bummed out for not being
able to go with Ging.
Gon replies to this by stating that even if
he did go with Ging, he would probably get
in his way, however it probably would have
been a different matter if he could still
use Nen.
He then confesses that he now realizes that
he really didn't want to meet Ging, but that
finding him was just his goal.
When Mito agrees with Gons explaination of
his father, she says that Ging didnt have
the qualities of a father and Gon cheeckily
replies that it must be father like son and
maybe he wasnt actuall cut out to be a son,
to which Mito violently rejects.
Gon cracks up laughing aswell before explaining
that he was just joking.
When he calms down, he stares into his glass
and says that it didnt cross his mind that
he should stay with him because he’s his
dad, BUT if he had been able to use nen still
and had felt how truly awesome and powerful
he is, then he wouldve most likely wanted
to go with him.
Mito sums their conversation up by stating
that he was now stuck with her and leaves
the room, only to return with two huge piles
of papers, informing the poor young man that
these books were all the documents Gon was
going to have to fill in, to which Gon recoils
screaming out in a comical manner not realizing
he ever had to do desk work within the associastion.
Having ended the call with Gon, Ging encounters
a member who informs him that the Expedition
Team had divided into two groups, those who
won't take Ging's money and those who will,
yet since Pariston considers him No.2 they
wont object to him being second now!.
BUT then states that all this disunity will
lead to chaos, so to avoid it they decided
to not listen to any of his orders until atleast
everyone accepts the money.
As Ging had also guessed they were hired by
Beyond through Pariston, Ging could consider
them to be mediators and it did not matter
to them if he looked down on them for this.
Another member then confesses that even if
they ganged up, they would be no match against
Ging, Yet Ging kinda feels that somethings
just not right with the situation and replies
by saying that they dont have to lie, as he
knows theyre all indeed experts.
As Ging states his reasons to believe that
the members of Beyond's expedition team are
specialists, pretty much just explaining the
entire dynamic of how their group works and
so on, Pariston confesses to himself that
Ging's thought process was similar to him
and that this was the first time he had actually
started to grow to hate someone.
Ging then drops a damn bomb and says that
the ten of the members here obviosly isnt
everyone in the group, so to solve that initial
issue of payments, he tells Pariston to tell
the others he’ll pay them upfront aswell!
As Pariston replies, telling him he’ll let
everyone know, he thinks to himself that he
wants to see what he’d do to someone he
truly HATES!
Meanwhile over in a banging dance club, two
seci ass peasent females are invited to the
hotel room of the price who has the Scarlet
eyes's.
After a quick glance to eachother the girls
both accept the invitation.
Arriving at a massive hotel entirely owned
by the prince of Kakin, they are filled with
awe at the pure beauty of his house, asking
if the Prince lived here all by himself.
The Prince replies to this by saying that
he never really feels lonely, as he always
invites people on over and asked the girls
to tell him about themselves.
Yet as the majority of you probably foresaw,
Tserriednich is later seen having a shower,
then later a bath while talking to someone
named Mark on the phone.
He complains to him about how the girls were
oblivious to what was happening around the
world and were only interested in fashion.
Sitting there with the floor soaked in blood,
the prince then asks him to send in another
pair of women.
(this is probably the dark side of the price
that Mizaistom was refering too when talking
with Kurapika, most likely due to the dues
overwhelming influence within the Kakin family
they cant arrest or probably even tell him
to stop his vile acts)
Meanwhile in her office, Cheadle is ordered
by the IPA Director to make Beyond sign a
contract saying that if he breaks the rules
even once, he will spend his entire life in
jail.
He states that he doesnt want to imagine what
would happen if Beyond does manage to escape
and then on top of that make a discovery known
to the whole world declaring it as something
he found on his own.
If this was to be the case he threatens Cheadle,
telling her that her future wont be so bright
if this happens..
Heading backdown to the cells with the new
contract, Cheadle hands it to Beyond and tells
him to read it.
He agrees with the rules of the contract reading
the majority of it aloud, saying that it was
exactly like he had already predicted.
With him not objecting Beyond ends up signing
the contract before striking the pen into
the contract, causing it to stick into the
pad below him.
He then ominously explains that only three
more things remain!
Qualifications, The Means and A contract!
Back in the car, Mizaistom asks Kurapika what
he’ll do with the prince after they take
the Scarlet Eyes back, to which Kurapika replies
that he’ll yeild to most demands, all he
wants is to get the eyes back.
Mizaistom questions him again, this time asking
him what he will do if the prince resists.
But Kurapika replies by saying that he’s
encountered two people in the past who said
that they would rather die than give him what
he wants..
He states that none of them were dead but
both of them had a 'change of heart', and
states that he was sure that the prince will
follow suit.
Big brain heart chain choking technique, Hisoka
walking around right now sulking cause Chrolo
cant use his nen!
Having reached the Hunter Association's office
the due and are greeted a by a surprised Leorio
and Cheadle whos also with him.
Cheadle leads them to the room in which the
other Zodiacs are seated, and the meeting
with the two new Zodiacs begin.
She then begins the meeting by informing the
Zodiacs that these specific nations are the
ones that make up the V5 which because of
Kakins recent mess has now been turned into
the V6 with them as the sixth seat.
She then states that the V6 had tried numerous
times to enter the Dark Continent but have
failed each and every time due to those "Five
Threats" ive brought up multiple times throughout
the video.
She then proceeds to inform them that the
danger rank of the Five Threats has risen
from rank B to A, which even surpasses the
Chimera Ants who were a B level threat.
Cheadle then reveals their objective: to capture
at least one of the Five Threats, survive
the trip back home and deal with Beyond in
the process, which if you think about it is
just pure insanity as the BIG MAN NETERO himself
was barely able to defeat Meruem in their
battle with the help of man made weaponry,
I dont know the strength of the other members
in the Zodiacs as of yet, but this is just
insanity to me at the moment, I just cant
picture Leorio being able to take down or
even assist in defeating a A rank threat...
Anyways Cheadle then inquires asking anyone
has a question to which Kurapika raises his
hand stating that he has a few.
When given permission to speak, he asks all
the Zodiacs if they had identified all of
Beyond's allies who are inside the Association.
He then proceeds to explain the reasoning
of his question, stating that as Beyond was
expecting his father's death instead of having
to defeat him himself, so he must have planned
his involvement within the association with
someone beforehand.
He also on top of dropping that bomb manages
to confirm the theory that Pariston and the
Temp Hunters were some of Beyond's allies.
Mizaistom, realizing that Kurapika's statements
could lead to certain complications, leads
him outside and reveals that he and Cheadle
had come to the same conclusion as he (Kurapika)
did, and requests him not to mention anything
about moles infront of the Zodiac again (as
it would put the mole on alert), to which
Kurapika agrees.
When the two return, all of the Zodiac members
reveal the roles they will be playing in their
voyage to the Dark Continent.
BUUUT WE AINT GONNA GO INDEPTH ON EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THEIR NAMES AND WHY THEY ARE APART
OF THE ZODIACS BECAUSE THIS VIDEO IS ALREADY
EVOOOLVING INTO SOMETHING WAY LONGER THAN
IT SHOULD BE.
LIKE HAVING NEVER READY HXH BEFORE THE AMMOUNT
OF INFORMATION STUFFED INTO THIS MANGA COULD
EASILY CREATE A NOVEL ITS JUST THAT INDEPTH
AT POINTS!
Soo enough of my crazy ramblings, now we actually
skip ahead one month and find ourselves back
in Beyonds lair as Ging shows the people there
a cheeky little trick called (Pip-Play).
Which just the ability to manipulate pip msized
balls of nen into lilttle animals.
While the other members try to master the
trick, Curly approaches Ging and challenges
him on a vocabulary match to see who knew
the most words of the Ancient Kappe language
that began with 'N’.
Ging as you could imagine comfortably wins
the contest and inturn Curly finally accepts
him as Number 2.
Pariston then suddenly shows up and informs
Ging that all the assassins that were sent
in the 289th Hunter Exam failed and acknowledges
the ability of his replacement in the Zodiacs
(obviously big Kurapika as he had been able
to easily pick them all out).
Just then, Muherr, along with 2 other Hunter
Exam participants, arrive and comment that
he (Kurapika) is rumored to be able to read
minds.
When questioned about his early arrival, he
states that he didn't even need to see the
results to know that he didn't pass.
Having sat down he then orders Ging to go
away as he was previously on the association's
side.
Yet, Ging corrects him by saying that when
it comes to the idea of how freedom is considered,
he was more closer to Beyond than the association.
He then states that he’s glad to help Beyond
be free but he cant give Pariston a pass as
his true goal is to help beyond and deter
the sname Pariston.
Muherr replies to this by saying that he didn't
buy it.
But Usamen interrupts him, affirming Ging's
claim that he wasn't on the association's
side.
Musher becomes surprised by the member's testimony,
asking him since when did he accept Ging as
a friend.
The member replies to this by saying he still
hated the dudes guts but lets just sit back
and see how it goes for a few days.
Just then the other Hunter Exam participants
arrive saying that they wont be waiting as
beyond is there only boss they don't care
about some irrelevant number 2.
They then present Ging and Pariston two options,
either Pariston leaves the expedition team,
or Ging leaves the expedition team.
Neither Ging nor Pariston agrees with either
of the options.
Instead, Ging produces a third option while
Pariston produces a fourth, either the assassins
will leave, or the assassins will die.
Instantly Muherr's henchmen use conjured guns
to shoot aura bullets directly at Ging and
Pariston, who easily manage to dodge out of
the way and escape through an underground
passage.
Ging complains about them having a bad temper,
to which Pariston says that he’s not as
crazy as expected.
Ging tells him to shut up aswell as Pariston
actually provoked them in the first place.
Hearing this the sly ray cheekily jokes that
he was just going along with what Ging had
said.
After gaining a bit of distance between the
two, Pariston asks if they should fight back,
to which Ging agrees, but wants to do it "gently".
He analyzes their abilities noting that their
emitters who have to conjure guns to fight.
Seeing him preparing to attack, Pariston asks
if it is okay for him to watch use his ability,
but cause Gings literally a Chad and not a
dad he responds affirmatively saying that
it aint no problem.
Watching with a gaze of amazement, Pariston
witnesses Ging reproduces Leorio's "remote
punch" by continuously slamming the ground
over and over again allowing him to send a
blast of aura thru the ground towards the
approaching brutes, before suddenly reappearing
above the surface and pummelling the trio
of unsuspecting mercenaries'.
Pariston asks if his ability is the copy kind
but Ging explains that he just has this random
talent to be able to imitate someone's ability
if it is a physical type and he has been hit
by it.
Continuing on his brutal shows of dominance,
Ging surmises on how leorio must've been palpating
his patients and using his aura like an ultra
sound.
Through this he assumes that his Nen ability
was the result of experimentation with aura
and tapping.
Then literally flexing on pariston some more
he again uses the same ultra sound like technique
to discover two enemies on the other side
of a wall.
Imagining those said enemies have a tumor
or a blood clot that can't be reached with
normal medical equipment, he shoots two aura
bullets through the wall completely taking
down the unsuspecting henchmen.
After using that Same ability again, he confirms
that there are no more enemies coming after
them.
Pariston speculates it is because they have
given up, but Ging disagrees, stating they
must assume the mission was completed.
He reveals he has known all along the whole
thing was actually staged by Pariston, and
the biggest mistake in his attempt to fool
Ging was that the angry guy with the Mohawk
didnt bring up the faith possible choice of
both Ging and Pariston leaving; although he
admits that he might have gone with it if
it had been presented so it was probably wise
to not offer it.
He states he’s gone along with Pariston's
show only because he felt bad for the ones
who were forced to play it, but he says that
if the former Rat wants to see his real abilities,
he has to come at him himself.
Back in the lounge now as the henchmen clean
up the remnants of the couch they blasted
to bits before, Muherr expresses his perplexity
about their scheme having been figured out,
since he thought his acting was good.
Ging mocks him, plainly imitating one of his
lines, and irritating the mercenary in a joking
manner.
However, Ging states that Muherr should be
more worried about his soldiers than his acting
since they are too weak to face the Dark Continent
alone, maybe only backup reserves at the best.
Sipping his drink, the mercenary replies that's
exactly what they are and the soldiers who
also add in their two cents state their duties
are limited to reconnaissance, artillery support,
and covering fire, while the shooting itself
will be covered by golem.
Ging recognizes him as a symbiotic type Nen
user which Muherr confirms before explaining
that Golem himself conjures a powerful, heavy
weapon that is manned by an Emitter who creates
the bullets: this way, both the weapon and
bullets are stronger than they would be separate.
Ging understands Golem was also the one who
gave the firearms to the henchmen and praises
the adaptability of the tactic.
Muherr continues explaining, for mid to long-term
group warfare, carrying real guns loaded with
Nen bullets greatly increases the efficiency
on the battlefield.
Golem and the other 10 men with assault and
recon duties make up the "Stone Wall" squad,
the legendary unit which came out of the Lubo
civil war without a single casualty.
Ging is impressed by Golem's abilities and
asks it its real name, but a distorted voice
replies that "Golem" is how it is called by
its comrades and declares that further enquires
will not be answered.
Confused and curious, Muherr informs Ging
that he has known Golem for over three years,
and still does not know anything about who
pilots it.
Ging admits that he was expecting it, as Golem
has been giving off that "don't talk to me"
vibe.
Getting down to business now, Ging asks Muherr
to convince the other members of Beyond's
group to take his money since he’s in charge
of all the divisions.
The mercenary responds that he was fine with
having the Hunter as number 2 until he offered
to give them money.
Him along with all his mem think soldiers
value each other's trust more than anything,
the rumor that some of them could be bought
would lead to them being ostracized.
The fact that Ging was tossing his money around
as if it had no consequence was a cause of
great anger to him as, like the title of a
book or the place where the remote is put
on the table, something had already been decided
in merit, and trying to change it so carelessly
only had negative repercussions, to the point
many members even considered quitting.
Muherr then demands that Ging explains himself,
but the Hunter can't.
He can only say he is sorry and, since he
can't take back the money from those who have
accepted it as that would just add to this
mess, suggests to settle the matter with donations
to the Norwell Fund, for the families of fallen
soldiers.
Which is this whole trust fund type foundation
that supports the families of fallen mercenaries.
So obviously this hits home for muherr.
Taken by surprise, Muherr asks him if he is
serious, as by opening a grandchild account,
he won't be able to refuse requests by the
grandfather account.
Ging replies that it's for the best, as it
shows his determination and won't risk stirring
up any weird rumors.
Muherr inquires why he is so keen on giving
them his money, and Ging admits that he doesn't
know.
He often ends up in the kind of situation
where he talks a lot and then wonders why
he's done it, but probably the main reason
was that he knew the expedition members aren't
the kind of people who would be bought by
money, so he thought that if they were to
take it, it would mean they have accepted
him.
Perhaps it was also because he was happy there
were other fools like him around.
He confesses he had planned to go to the Dark
Continent on his own, but the fuss caused
by Beyond's own expedition had made it impossible,
so he was very angry, but at the same time
aware that Beyond had been preparing for even
longer than he has.
When he came to his base, he had not straightened
out his feelings yet, and only wanted to blow
off some steam.
He does not even remember how the whole money
topic originated.
Mascher though, remember that thumb looking
dude, well he jumps in to give his take on
what happened.
Mascher explains asked Ging himself, while
he was arguing with Pariston.
Initially, Mascher believed he was just a
troublemaker with a provocative facade and
the tendency to try to manipulate others,
but during the discussion, he heard the two
former Zodiacs speaking about Isaac Netero,
Ging's feelings toward the Dark Continent.
Mascher and Marione were ready to fight in
the event disorder rose, but since they prioritized
solving the problem, they recognized that
Ging's lead had undeniable merits.
Muherr still doesn't exactly understand how
this is related to the money, Ging though
admits he was just trying to be cool about
it, at the time he didnt foresee that it would
cause such an uproar.
Although his relationship with Pariston is
complicated, he is not concocting anything:
he just wants to thwart Pariston's schemes
and help Beyond be free.
Golem joins the conversation, asking Muherr
why he had not told them sooner.
The mercenary awkwardly responds that, in
order to quell the disorder, he had to get
Ging to acknowledge his shame.
He urges Golem to try and understand his feelings,
yet, to no avail causing Ging to feel like
that too is his fault.
In the end, Muherr accepts and says he'll
talk to the soldiers, provided the money goes
to the Nowell Foundation.
Plus, despite Ging being the number 2 in the
operation, it will be the mercenaries that
will give the orders to everyone on the battlefield
and those orders are absolute.
Ging agrees and salutes, while comically answering
"Sir!
Yes Sir!"
Which helps reminds me of Gon, honestly dude
is just a grown up Gon on that world smoke.
Anyways with the matter finally settled.
Muherr asks Pariston if the ones who are returning
to the base will accept Ging, and quickly
receives an affirmative answer.
Pariston tells Ging that, since the infiltration
failed, he may now send his money to the list
of contacts he is transmitting him and congratulates
him for getting the cemented position amount
the group.
However as we know Ging is a multiverse level
theorist and states that his authority is
only in name as everyone will continue to
do what he says, either way, he is willing
to let Pariston lead, as he wants to watch,
but the latter declines, wanting to see how
he indeed handles things.
Ging smirks back and declares that he will
not hold back.
BTW just gonna cut myself off here, since
the next arc after this one may never be completed
depending on how frequently Togashi releases
chapters, hopefully these next 33 that are
confirmed will complete it ,but if not, be
sure to let me know what fights throughout
the succession arc you want me to cover and
honestly push this video to like 5k likes
and ill break that arc down into parts so
I can cover at least some of it.
Annnyways back over with Big C At the final
part of the 289th Hunter Exam.
There she asks the applicants whether they
knew about Beyond's expedition to the Dark
Continent, and if they knew, how and when
did they get access to that information.
The participants were also asked how they
would explain their information in the best
way to a person that did not know about this
and on what the merits of receiving this information
beforehand were.
In another room, Kurapika and Mizaistom are
trying to verify what the applicants say.
He concludes that the first examinee doesn't
know, the second Muherr has mixed truth in
with lies, and that the third one is hiding
extremely important information.
Kurapika is surprised at the number of people
that have cleared the thermography and lie
detectors.
He then explains his abilities to Mizaistom,
and the limitations it has.
Obviously I'm not gonna bore you all with
repeating stuff that was explained ages ago
in the anime.
So after that he thinks about the possibility
that if the enemy has someone on their side
that can manipulate another's memory, then
his chain would likely not work as that person
wouldn't even realize they were lying to begin
with.
Skipping away over to Prince T with the crazy
name.
Well he gets a call from his elder brother
Benjamin who's this jacked ass dude and mans
also wrestling with a damn lio.
Benjamin informs him that their father has
decided that whoever survives this expedition
becomes the new king.
Thankful of God, Tserriednich warns his brother
that he is the one who is going to be the
king.
After the call ends, Tserriednich then gets
another one fom one of his bodyguards called
Theta, she informs him that all five of his
staff have passed the hunter exam.
She explained that if they lied or hid any
information from the Hunter Association, they
wouldve been rejected.
She then confirms that the bodyguards of the
princes that haven't participated in the exam
were Benjamin's and Tyson's or the first and
sixth princes respectively.
On top of that all of the bodyguards from
the seventh prince, Luzurus, failed the exams,
having heard everything Tserriednich orders
Theta to return to her defensive duties and
to tell everyone to get an understanding of
the Black Whale.
Back at the Hunter Exam, Mizaistom confirms
that there is no one within the Zodiacs that
has powers to manipulate somebody's memory.
He continues to say that within the Zodiacs,
there were three factions, with Ging and Pariston
being exceptions.
He knows all of the powers of the Hunters
of his own faction (which includes Botobai,
Cheadle, and Ginta) but doesn't know the powers
of the other members.
The duo are obviously suspicious of Juhnde
and Muherr, and wonder if they were purposely
sent in as decoys by some powerful spies.
Mizai infers that the spy may be a traitor
within the Zodiacs, since Pariston left so
soon after losing the presidential election.
Hearing this Kurapika volunteers to find the
traitor using his chain ability and will wait
in a nearby room while he confronts them.
Suddenly re-entering the room Mizaistom abruptly
confronts the Zodiacs about there being a
possible spy within the group.
He asks everyone to once again reveal their
abilities, but before he can proceed any further
Kanzai starts raging out.
Not fazed though the cow zodiac Explains that
he would've actually helped Beyond if he had
met him before, he would've gladly tried to
help make his dream come true and wouldn't
have changed his mind after seeing the chairman's
final video.
However its a question of sequence, not betrayal
and that's why he’s asking him to reveal
their abilities…
continuing Mizai reveals his abilities to
them all and explains how it works exactly.
Elsewhere the megabrain Kurapika watches the
whole thing on a monitor in a separate room
via a hidden camera.
He uses his sneaky ability to quickly scan
the zodiacs, passing off the ones who aren't
spies, however he eventually finds out that
the
traitor
is
the monkey Saiyu.